[Music]
[Applause]
thank you keep coming up they've gone to
so music has always played a major role
in the motion picture experience we know
my quest
[Applause]
you're ready now your turn hit it the
first time a film talk that you're cute
that he hits say it's mine already it's
sang in the LJ Al Jolson in the jazz
story good work yeah
try to imagine Casablanca without as
time goes by
for the way we were without the way we
were or the bridge on the river kwai
without the nominees for original song
are miss Sally's Blues sister from the
color purple
music by Quincy Jones and rod Templeton
lyric by Quincy Jones brought temper to
that Lionel Richie
the power of love from back to the
future music by Chris Hayes and Johnny
colla lyric by Huey Lewis say you say me
from white knights music and lyric by
Lionel Richie separate lives from white
knights music and lyric by Stephen
Bishop Sakura fries from a chorus line
music by Marvin Hamlisch and lyric by
Edward Cleavon got that out of my pocket
fool
the winner is Lionel Richie for say you
[Applause]
[Music]
outrageous in the truest sense of the
word I will say to you that this
represents a dream come true many many
years of believing and dreaming and a
lot of friends and a lot of family that
said you can do it just keep on trying
hard I want to say to all of them and to
all the people that have supported me
over the years thank you very much for
keeping up with my foolishness to the
Academy I want to say to you again si
for the first time thank you and this is
outrageous
[Applause]
[Applause]